good morning everyone and welcome to the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences today
we will announce the various Riksbank
prize in Economic Sciences in memory of
Alfred Nobel this price is financed by
the central bank of Sweden awarded by
the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
and included in the Nobel Prize ceremony
the first prize was awarded in 1969
through an efficient in beragon and it
is now being awarded for the 50th time
so ladies and gentlemen we are
celebrating an anniversary with
half-century of economics prizes
my name is Jordan Hansen I'm the
secretary-general of the Academy and
with me here at the podium is to my
right the chairman of the Prize
Committee professor param Bay and on my
left
professor parasail who is a member of
the Prize Committee and will tell us
more about the research that's being
awarded today this year's prize is about
innovation climate and economic growth
Oris please
Haarlem in buffoon climate or economy
affects American commerce cops Academy
nor Adobe's latitude tell us various
tricks banks priests economics cretins
cocktail alfred nobel's mean for all
sugar and Orton in health until William
the Nordhaus Ferrari integrated climate
rendering our along 60 macroeconomic
analysis who mentor helped until Paul M
Romer ferrate integrator technique
skills we cling along SiC the
macroeconomic analysis the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences has today decided to
award the various tricks Bank Prize in
Economic Sciences in memory of Alfred
Nobel for 2018 with one-half to William
Dean order house for integrating climate
change into long run macroeconomic
analysis
and the other half to Paul M Romer for
integrating technological innovations
into long run macroeconomic analysis and
you have now some biographical data
about our new new laureates above me as
here dr. William Nordhaus was born in
Albuquerque in New Mexico in the United
States in 1941 and is currently at Yale
University in New Haven Connecticut in
the u.s. dr. Paul Romer was born in
Denver Colorado in the United States in
1955 he's currently working at New York
University School of Business and was
previously the chief economist of the
World Bank and with that I like to turn
over to param bay the chairman of the
Prize Committee to give us some remarks
about this year's prize so the causes
and consequences of economic growth is
an issue of global importance and
long-term implications because just a
few percent of growth can accumulate
over decades and when it does that it
radically changes people's lives the
growth of the economy is determined both
by nature which provides the necessary
resources for growth and by the current
state of knowledge which determines how
well we can manage these scarce
resources that nature provides but can
we really rely on the market economy to
keep on generating these new knowledge
necessary for long-run sustained growth
and how should we deal with the negative
effects of economic growth on nature for
example the climate change caused by
increasing emission of greenhouse gases
this year's laureates have provided us
with tools that are crucial for
understanding how the economy interacts
with nature and with knowledge and which
policies help generate sustained and
sustainable long-term economic growth in
the mid 1970s as natural scientists are
become increasingly worried about the
effects of greenhouse gas emissions on
the climate William Nordhaus started
studying the interplay between the
market economy and the global climate
about ten years later in the late 1980s
Paul Romer started to work on trying to
formulate a new model of how
technologies develop in the market
economy and the models that Nordhaus and
Romer created have significantly
broadened the analysis of economic
growth and I provided the standard
framework for research and policymaking
in the areas of technological
development and climate change thank you
bad No thank you sell I'm ready to give
us some background about the research
that's being awarded please thank you so
this year's laureate laureates they have
made macroeconomics go to a truly global
scale and address long-run problems
truly long-run problems and they have
very short questions Nordhaus asks how
should economies appropriately address
climate change
Romer asks how economies can ensure a
healthy rate of technological progress
these are questions that are of vital
importance to human well-being but it's
easier to ask questions than to answer
them and they both realize that the
frameworks for addressing the questions
we're actually missing in economics so
their task became to come up with
framework so that you could ask the
questions in 1994 Nordhaus was done at
least with his first complete integrated
assessment model it's a framework that
describes the interplay between the
climate and the economy in 1990 Romer
published a complete theory of what's
called endogenous technical change which
allows us to understand the economic
roots of technological progress so
Nordhaus built a model that he called
dice
dynamic integrated model of climate and
the economy and it has three
interdisciplinary parts modules one is
take on the economy another one is the
carbon cycle and the third one is the
climate in the economic model Nordhaus
builds on traditional growth theory but
it adds fossil fuel as an important good
for businesses and households they use
it for their energy needs and this gives
rise to carbon dioxide co2 emissions
carbon dioxide moves into the atmosphere
and goes into carbon circulation among
different reservoirs that happens in the
carbon cycle module and finally the
climate module describes how the climate
is affected by the greenhouse gas carbon
dioxide the climate also effects the
economy by causing damages by clomid the
global warming and that's also described
in the economic module so now we have
the pieces that are needed to do the
analysis and I'll show you an example of
how dice is put to use this is a graph
that shows us what the model predicts
for carbon dioxide emissions over time
in this under the assumption that we
don't change our current climate
policies here's another graph that's
what comes about if you do a calculation
that's similar to what governments do
when they do cost-benefit analysis and
think about pros and cons that leads to
carbon tax and that curbs emissions the
next one is also a same type of
calculation but where the government
puts much higher weight on future
generations and you see that emissions
fall even more finally a similar path is
arrived at if you set a maximum degree
of warming to two and a half degrees so
these kinds of calculations and
different generations of dice have been
key input into the IPCC reports Paul
Romer in the 1980s puzzled over the
following
of data here you see growth experiences
of three countries they're just examples
but they Ellis trait something important
Chad grew between 1960 and 1981 by minus
2% per year
Singapore grew by almost 8 percent plus
8 percent per year and the Philippines
were like in the middle and they
actually grew like the world as a whole
so you see huge income gaps opening up
over the course of only two decades this
has staggering consequences for human
welfare and rumor concluded that likely
technological growth was behind the
long-run economic growth observed in
these different countries so he asked
himself what explains his technological
growth in market economies and the crux
was to understand ideas he thought ideas
for new technology where do they come
from and his vision was to build a
framework where ideas give rise to new
ideas which give rise to new ideas
propelling growth over time so what kind
of a product is an idea he had to come
up with a new way of thinking about
goods and services and I'll try to
illustrate this here with a rectangle
and so he he thought of normal goods
from the textbooks as rival Goods here's
an example of a nice dish of Swedish
meatballs that would be a rival good its
rival because when I eat the meatballs
nobody else can eat them not very deep
but here's an idea an idea is a non
rival good this is the Pythagorean
theorem and when I use it and people use
it all over the world at the same time I
don't prevent anyone else from using it
they can use it for free that's a very
valuable idea but it's not the kind of
ideas that markets provide here's
another idea what is this this is a
computer code but you can't really see
that it's computer code why because it's
encrypted so there's a dimension of
ideas which is that can be excludable or
non-excludable the theorem cannot be
excluded
but a computer could code can and Romer
realized that it's the excludable type
of types of goods that can be provided
by markets here's something in between
somewhat excludable this is the recipe
for them Swedish meatballs it's in
Swedish so it's it's hard to understand
for most of the world's population so he
focused on this part of the rectangle
ideas are non rival for market
production they need to be partly
excludable restricting access is key but
it's also tricky because restricting
access means that they will be monopoly
power and we know there are problems
with monopoly power so Roma incorporated
this new pirate paradigm this new way of
thinking about goods and services into
growth theory and built a simulation
model much like Nord houses dice model
so these two researchers they have asked
different questions they have worked
entirely separately but they have many
things in common one is that they build
on the same growth theory framework they
also ask questions of a truly global and
long-run macroeconomic nature they don't
provide definitive answers why because
these answers are these the questions
are huge and very difficult to answer
definitively but they offer us the
methodological tools to begin finding
them in the form of dynamic simulation
models they also offer us great advice
in terms of thinking systemically about
economic policy so Nordhaus highlights
what economists call negative negative
spillover effects and here the idea is
that when firms and when businesses and
households use fossil fuel they pay for
the production of the fuel but not for
the damages they cause when they
generate emissions so he advocates a
global carbon tax and he shows that how
to how to compute it Romer highlights
spillover effects too but in this case
they're positive here the idea is that
when an innovator come up with it comes
up with a new idea the innovator may
make some profit but doesn't fully
get the benefits from how this idea
helps other innovators so this means
that you may need R&D subsidies on top
of a carefully designed patent system
the impact clearly of the research of
this of this year's laureates has been
enormous it's had huge amounts it led to
huge amounts of subsequent research and
in the policy sphere it had immense
practical relevance for global
macroeconomic policy making thank you
very much for the excellent presentation
and now we may have one of our new
Knoller new laureates with us on the
phone line dr. Romer are you there yes I
am good morning good morning this is
Jordan Hansen who spoke with you about
half an hour ago and gave you the good
news we're having a press conference now
here at the Royal Academy of Sciences
and we have number of journalists here
and I'm sure some of them would like to
ask you some questions yes we have a
gentleman over here would like to start
I think he's from Swedish television
please okay yeah thank you
this is good saddam dude for Swedish
television in Stockholm I must ask you
you wrote a paper a couple years ago in
New York when you were very critical
against your colleagues on the current
state of national economics what do you
think about those thoughts today well
there in some sense what both bill
mordhaus and I have been thinking about
is the process of science
it's what the Nobel Prizes recognized
many of them saroja and science is the
most important social systems humans
have ever developed but part of how
science works
is by criticism and challenge there's no
authority who can shut things down
there's no Supreme Court different
individual scientists say what they
think is is right and when they think
their colleagues are wrong they they
will say that
and so by criticizing over some
dimensions where I thought there were
some weaknesses I was really just trying
to do the thing that has always been
part of the scientific method still
Vogel moth as you called it in this
science um I'm sorry
is it still oh yes yeah for them oh yeah
this is a total issue because math is a
language just like you know Swedish in
English or languages math is very good
for producing results like and
explaining results like the Pythagorean
theorem that pair of mentioned so math
can be used very productively in a very
helpful way but sometimes people use it
in a way which creates a kind of a fog
of misunderstanding and part of what I
was pushing for and I think I you know
everyone needs to keep pushing for is
that we all try as hard as we can to
communicate communicate clearly because
this is part of what pairs presentation
brings out is that knowledge is valuable
only if it's communicated to other
people and it won't be accurately
communicated if people are vague or
confusing in their communication so is
there still some
in our science of course as logins our
communication on everything there's
always rumors could do better and it's
part of my job and help push that we all
do better thank you very much now we
have a question from Associated Press
hello first of all congratulations sir
on the prize Devi Keaton from The
Associated Press
now this prize comes at a very timely
moment the IPCC released a report today
with major climate scientists saying
that the world has only a dozen years to
prevent global warming past 1.5 degrees
unless which could then if it's not
secede yield to serious risks of drought
flooding extreme heat and other
environmental crises to what extent can
this prize highlight not just the
environmental risk but also the economic
risk to the planet if the world is not
able to find an effective solution to
combat climate change thank you very
much yeah um so first let me say that
it's it's a shame that bill isn't on the
call because you know he'd be best
positioned to speak to this I also want
to be clear that the economics that I
was struggling with about ideas were it
was this was a case where I could draw
on work that bill had done about
monopolies and patents and ideas in his
own PhD thesis so there's a direct
connection between my work and Bill's
earlier work I can't speak for him but I
think you would agree with me on the
following point it it's entirely
possible for humans to produce less
carbon there's some trade-offs but once
we start to try and reduce carbon
emission will be surprised that it
wasn't as hard as we anticipated I read
a little bit about the concern people
had when we addressed the problem of the
ozone hole caused by chlorofluorocarbons
there were many people saying this with
enormous ly expensive and difficult and
and then once we actually said about
reducing emissions of
chlorofluorocarbons it was a non-event
so I think the danger with the very
alarmist portraits that people are
giving for which there's real basis is
that it will make people feel apathetic
and hopeless it's entirely doable for us
even now to start bringing down the path
of emissions and to protect a better
future in climate and it's entirely
possible for us to have better standards
of living as far into the future as we
we can see so I said I was want a
conditional optimist if we do the right
thing everything can keep going better
but it is time that we start doing the
right thing
thank you very much for those thoughtful
words we have a question the gentleman
over there
dr. Roman congratulations my name is
Yvonne shriek from longest narrator in
Stockholm I know that you have put
forward rather controversial and bold
ideas concerning how to deal with a
global migration and that was some years
ago how do you look upon this issue now
I want to borrow a phrase that's
attributed to Winston Churchill I don't
know if he said it but my suggestion for
dealing with potential migration flows
is the worst idea that's ever been
proposed except for all the others the
problem is is that there are no perfect
solutions to a problem with enormous
human consequences and what I was trying
to do was encourage people to think
about some possibilities
that words perfect there's no question
they wouldn't be perfect but they would
be better than what we have now and I
think better than any of the
alternatives that that others have
suggested so as I think people have come
to realize we don't have good
alternatives and as they've realized the
scale there are hundreds of millions of
people who say they want to leave the
country where they were born I think
that you this may be a time where we
also start to think a little bit about
what could we do to give people who are
desperate to be safe desperate to have a
job
Jeff desperate for their children to
have a future what could we do to make
it possible for them to to pursue those
those goals the things that we all
pursue thank you very much now we have
time for one or two more questions was
it who was next to trade lady over there
please congratulations I'm itchin access
song from Green Post and China radio I
asked a simple question how have you
expected that you win the prize what was
your reaction when you heard these news
thank you
well I got I didn't I got called I got
two phone calls this morning and I
didn't answer either one because I
thought it was some spam call so I
wasn't I wasn't expecting it surprise
but finally we were able to establish
contact
unfortunately before the press
conference yes the gentleman over there
I'm hungry and Swedish TV for
congratulations from me as well in what
way do you think the prize can
contribute to focus on the climate
questions
I'm going to make a conjecture about
politics which isn't my direct lower
area of expertise but my sense is that
optimism is is part of what helps
motivate people to attack a hard problem
and I think one of the problems with the
current situation is that many people
think that dealing with the protecting
the environment will be so costly and so
hard that they just want to ignore the
problem they want to deny it exists they
can't deal with it
I hope the prize today could help
everyone see that humans are capable of
amazing accomplishments when we set
about trying to do something and if we
all have we set about making the policy
changes that are required here we can
absolutely make substantial progress
towards protecting the environment and
do it without without giving up the
chance to sustain growth so I hope that
the the optimism will help us if Tovar
into taking the steps that we really
need to take thank you very much dr.
Romer and it will be more opportunities
to have dr. Romer questions and here is
views of these important issues in
December but so we look forward to
meeting you in December dr. Romer and
until then thanks for being with us
today and bye-bye thank you
and now questions to the panel
is everything crystal clear yes there is
a question over there the lady over
there thank you and this is Tonya from
Nordic Chinese times and we could see
that both awards are given to the people
who trying to think and global
macroeconomic issues so I wonder that
how the price were related to the
fluctuating and global economy
especially in terms of trade
protectionism and political uncertainty
thank you sir I don't honestly don't
think there is a strong tie between the
price and the areas that you brought up
they are important areas but they are
not really
they don't have much overlap with with
this year's price so how do you think
that the price will improve the
efficiency in emerging markets I don't
think it speaks to that very much I mean
there what what what what the price
talks about to some extent is is the
importance of knowledge growth and
technology growth but it's not very
specific so obviously emerging markets
benefit enormous ly from the technology
revolutions that the leading technology
countries go through because because
they can ride on the wave of technology
that innovators in mostly you know the
rich countries today contribute so in
that sense but I don't think it's it's
not a topic that we focus much on in
this particular price formulation yeah
if I can add to that both of these
prices are really about global problems
that you know the whole world needs to
get together to solve how to get the
right amount of technological progress
how to solve the global problem of
climate change and I guess if there's a
message that's relevant here
it's that we need to get together okay
to to get a global solution and to get a
global solution we also need to realize
you know rich countries need to realize
the problems that emerging markets have
with implementing some of these
solutions you know how when it comes to
patent protection when it comes to
emissions and so on so I guess the
message is that you know it's needed for
countries to cooperate globally to solve
some of these big questions so okay one
last question thank you
both witness of the price I've been
expected for a quite a long time but not
that they would get it to price together
and well one interpretation could be
that some people in the press committee
have found our climate and others have
found a growth and then we have made a
compromise but another receptor answer
is something really connecting these two
great economists but could you tell what
is done the link between the two yeah a
bit more than you've already told us
okay it's not the first interpretation
for sure I can also tell you that when
Paul Romer received the call he was
super happy that it was also given to
Nordhaus I mean he's clearly interested
in nor does this work they're interested
in each other's work and I think it's
because they are part they're part of
the same agenda to think about the long
run and to think about global issues so
and they're they're asking fundamental
questions extremely difficult questions
so they have these things in common but
they also have in common that they built
these tools that that are very much
alike they built simulation tools that
the rest of us can use and look at and
study and improve and so I think it's
it's this common base that they built
that's another thing in common they have
a similar view of how to think about
economic policy as well
as I am emphasizing the presentation
they both think in terms of market
failures but they're kind of different
in nature but it's the same type of
recipe that they offer so I think that
there's there's a lot of things in
common and and and in fact there is a
new literature coming out that that I
think Paul was was Apple Roman was
referring to which is that to address
some of the climate change issues you
really need to think about new
technologies that replace fossil fuel
maybe new technologies that can remove
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere
there's a range of technology solutions
I think without these technology
solutions it's gonna be very hard I
think that was implicit in one what Paul
Romer said so how can we think about
those things without having roamers
shoulders to stand on so I think there's
a lot of connections I think it's only
superficially that they look different
thank you and I think with that we'll
close this press conference and now
there will be opportunities for
individual interviews so thank you very
much for your interest and welcome back
in December or next year thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
parasail macroeconomics seems to be a
common term here what is the main
question of macroeconomics textbook and
basic economics it usually talks about
business cycles about short-run
fluctuations in economic activity like
unemployment is up or inflation is up or
down
this type of macroeconomics is a little
different you find it in textbooks but
it's very different because it's about
long-run where economic growth comes
from so so actually the textbooks have
been changed quite a lot since Romer did
his work and so that actually the the
part of the book that is about the
long-run issues has become longer and
many textbooks start with that now where
when they used to start with business
cycles say about that he asks where it
comes from I mean he wanted to
understand why some countries grow and
other countries don't grow and also why
though why the world grows at the rate
it does and what explains technological
progress and I think it was by asking
the question that he came up with ways
of thinking about it that influenced a
lot of other researchers and it led to
both empirical work and theoretical work
and actually an explosion in research so
what is the main motor of economic
growth it I think almost all economists
would say its technological change but
the question is where does that come
from like what why does it happen and
when does it happen you know nothing
happened during the many hundred years
before the Industrial Revolution in
terms of technological change and then
it all exploded but it hasn't been
totally even and but it's been ongoing
since the Industrial Revolution
and at 2% per year the the leading
countries are just kind of growing and
growing and it's because of
technological change in what we did Paul
Romer it's to think about why the
Kherson what are the good preconditions
for healthy growth and he thought about
things like how societies organized in
terms of patent systems in terms of
subsidies to oranjee so it's not enough
to have universities because
universities are crucial and there there
are people there at universities like
Rome himself they are rewarded by this
wonderful prizes but you also need
research in the market and that's what
he focused on so what makes it happen in
the market what what are the
circumstances you know judicial system
all kinds of things that create the
conditions for technological growth
that's what he was interested in then
you have to realize that once you come
up with great ideas it's important that
they spread that they spread to other
countries so so many countries I think
or or not original innovators but they
adopt technical ideas different kind of
products and ideas are different yes
exactly and by thinking deeply about why
ideas are so different than regular
shoo-shoo type products it's then you
get some other clue to how to think
about it and it was led to think about
many ideas are super cheap to replicate
once you get them but it's it's all
about getting the ideas and then that's
when all these institutional
preconditions come in that allow some
profits but not too much profits because
you don't want to restrict it too much
and how to manage that is a central
problem and I think all the people who
are at governments around the world
these days they think about it
the way he thinks about it because
they've read the textbooks
and they they understood that ideas are
different and that's just the framework
for thinking so somehow you have to give
birth to ideas but who has the
responsibility for that
well they if we live in market economies
it's not that this anybody responsible
you need to happen by itself and that's
what the market does these things and it
does it usually fairly well but he also
pointed to how it doesn't do it enough
maybe I'm in a case of ideas
so we've he emphasizes that you need to
give people patents that last for a
while to give them proper incentives to
do things to to innovate and and and you
may also need to subsidize research and
development ideas so I think governments
are to some extent responsible but a lot
of it happens by just market activity so
it's both and the other part of the
price has to do with climate change and
this is really a very hard problem in
both so many different parts of society
everything so how can one model with
well I think what what what Nordhaus did
was that he became very interested in
other sciences after his speech the in
degree maybe even before I don't know
but he did this interdisciplinary thing
which is very fashionable today but I
think in the 1970s it was a very common
that an economist would dig deep into
Natural Sciences and also discover
climate change as a potentially big
problem I mean most people for sure most
economists didn't think about it and
many others didn't either so so I guess
you had the early realization that you
needed to connect all these things and
build the framework for thinking about
them together so I think a lot of what
he did was to simplify the natural
science bits to the point where he could
think about them jointly with economics
so there is sort of you need to take
existing knowledge
make it digestible digestible for for
people like himself and for other
economists and ultimately for
policymakers so that that was a quite an
effort and in the in the early days he
he he asked limited questions but still
super interesting questions like what's
the best way of not exceeding two
degrees of warming a question that most
people are super interested in today he
asked like forty years ago but then he
asked more ambitious questions which is
okay but what is the best thing to do
overall let's not restrict attention
just to a particular temperature goal
how should we think about maybe what's
the right temperature golden and so on
so he he needed to invest for decades
before he was ready to adjust these more
difficult questions and as I said in my
presentation today in the press
conference it's we don't have final
answers but now can we can just follow
in his footsteps and if you don't like
exactly what it did on this we change it
and and that's what everybody's doing
now around the world the most last
report from this night is that we have
to stop the growth of temperature to at
1.5 big yeah I haven't I haven't had
time to read it because it just it came
out at midnight so not too many hours
ago so I have to look carefully and see
what it says 1.5 degrees is it oh yeah
there was to say what would it take to
get us to not exceed one and a half so
it's I don't think that the point was we
mustn't exceed one and a half it was
more what would it take is it even
possible and I think they that's my
reading without having studied it
carefully and the question is they say
it's possible it's very very hard and it
takes things like special efforts to
remove carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere future technology to to do
the job and
again that's that's the kind of thing
that Romer was interested in so the the
two areas are connected that way what
would be the answer to this ambition to
limit the growth of temporary I'm not
sure because I just know that he has
said that without advance new type of
geoengineering or advanced types of
removing carbon dioxide he I don't think
he thinks it's possible but that doesn't
mean that he thinks we shouldn't try it
I think he says it's extremely difficult
and you have to rely on future
technologies for doing these things to
work out and succeed I think what he
would say if I may guess is that you
should also figure out how much it costs
to do that it's not just a matter of
doing it at any cost so there is still a
cost-benefit calculation there I think
he would answer but you would have to
ask him for the details but what are the
policy recommendations to somehow curve
them for a long time been pushing the
idea of just using global carbon tax I
mean try to agree that all countries
roll large regions of countries should
tax carbon and as an economist this is
can obvious solution
I think it's gaining momentum the notion
of using carbon taxes I think the ideas
a little bit that if you have a sizable
carbon tax it will do several things but
one of them is to eliminate a lot of
fossil fuel that's not really so
productive anyway where it's it's
marginally profitable and then it will
not be used if it there's a tax on top
of that and that that's a good thing but
it might also induce more new
technologies that can replace fossil
fuel that will be out competed so I'm
guessing that this is what he would say
but I want to emphasize that the price
is not given for
particular policy conclusions this point
it's more methodological price so it's
really kind of the tools we need to
answer the kind of question you were
asking me now no not to kind of say what
to do and that's it so in part I'm just
speculating and we'll see what he has to
say when it comes to Stockholm
thank you very much back yourself